Prince Charles is the latest famous face
to test positive for the coronavirus
according to a palace spokesperson a 71
year old royal has not been to the
hospital his symptoms are mild and he's
in good spirits
in fact a source tells ET that the
Prince of Wales is quote doing well for
the palace Charles took the Cova 19 test
on Monday and his results came back
positive the following day Tuesday he
and his wife Camilla are currently
quarantined at their estate in Scotland
although the Duchess moved to another
area of the home to self isolate
following her husband's diagnosis
Camilla was also tested her results came
back negative
the palace confirms that the Duke and
Duchess of Cornwall remain in touch with
their families and Charles has notified
both his sons Prince William and Harry
the famous family was last seen together
publicly on March 9th at the
Commonwealth Day service at Westminster
Abbey according to the palace it's
impossible to determine who Charles
caught the virus from given the high
number of public engagements he's
carried out in recent weeks and the
preventative no handshake policy that
hasn't always been easy for Charles to
remember that was the 71 year old at the
National Prince's Trust Awards on March
11th now as for the Queen the palace
reports that she remains in good health
adding that she last saw Charles briefly
on the morning of March 12th the 93 year
old monarch is said to be following
advice regarding her health including
moving to Windsor Castle on March 19th
one week earlier than planned
[Music]